one of the most unusual rules of chess
is called castling this move was
invented to speed up the game and do two
things at once
when you castle your King moves toward
the safety of the corner and your Rupp
comes toward the action in the middle
you literally are moving two pieces at
once but accounts as just one move you
can castle in either direction left or
right in either case your King moves
over only two squares and then the rook
from that side is moved directly to the
other side of the King like this and
here's another example of Castle
castling is a great move with many
benefits if it is used at the right time
however there are a few conditions that
may prevent you from castling first off
you cannot castle when you are in check
you must first deal with the check
before trying to Castle secondly you
cannot castle if your King would castle
through a check or after castling your
King would land into a check next you
cannot castle if there are any pieces in
between your king and your rook it must
be completely empty in this position
both white and black have to move one
piece before they're able to castle
after Knight f3 and Bishop c5 for
example both sides are now able to
Castle kingside
finally you cannot castle if your King
has made any other move before or if the
rook you are castling with has already
moved it must be the first move for both
pieces in this position the only legal
castling move is for black since White's
King has already moved white cannot
castle notice black can only castle with
the rook on h8 because the other rook
has already moved
what is the notation for castling it
depends on if you Castle kingside
or Queen side in this position let's say
white castles King side the way you
would write it is 0-0 if black now
castles Queen side we would add one more
zero so it would be 0 - 0 - 0
one way that can help you remember this
is notice on the kingside there are 2
squares between the white king and the
rook notice 0-0 has two zeros so
kingside castling two squares two zeros
notice on the Queen side there's three
squares between the king and the rook
queenside castling has three zeros zero
- zero - zero now it's your turn to
castle